[Music]
well hello dear friends and Welcome to
our question and answer program I'd like
to know this program airs once a week uh
we receive your questions
online and uh then we study uh for uh to
discover what the answers are to the
questions and we share with uh you on
the air uh if you want to send your
questions to us you'll see the address
on the screen the electronic address TVM
tv.org once again TVM tv.org we'd be
delighted to receive your questions just
keep in mind that uh many times uh your
question will not not be answered
immediately because we have so many
questions and we put them in line
according to when we receive them but we
will definitely answer the question uh
down the line so keep tuning in uh as I
mentioned this is one of our favorite
programs that we do here at Secrets
unsealed in some TV uh because it drives
us to the Bible to do research
absolutely it is a benefit not only to
those who are viewing but it's a benefit
to us as well and I've learned a lot uh
Pastor Salasar from uh the questions
that have been sent in by the way let me
introduce our fellow worker here uh it
is David Salazar uh very beloved here
very active in the ministry he actually
uh is in charge of all of our Spanish
work here he does the Spanish I'd like
to know as a wonderful wife two
beautiful little daughters and uh it's
such a delight to have them here at
Secrets unsealed thank you for helping
out with this program Pastor thank you
Pastor bour as you mentioned is one of
our favorite programs to do together and
to really to study to be able to prepare
sometimes we run out of time but it's
important to really share from the word
of God and we hope that we are going to
be used to answer the questions today
amen so would you have a word of prayer
for us as we begin today ABS absolutely
let's
pray Heavenly Father we are thankful
once again to come to your throne of
grace and to know that you promise to
send your Holy Spirit to lead us into
all truth to guide us and to remember
the things you have uh said in your
scriptures so we pray Lord that as we
open your word that it would not be our
own thoughts or words or or own
reasoning but really would be your words
spoken through us that may bring an
answer and a guidance to those that are
watching and hearing I pray for this
program for those that are watching we
pray this in Jesus name amen
amen okay uh this question is a
multifaceted question uh it's relatively
long so I'm going to read it slowly so
that we get the answer
correct this comes from a Oliver
R and uh there's no information about
where it comes from and this is how it
reads concerning Steven's prayer when he
was being
stoned and the statement of Peter during
Pentecost when did Christ finish walking
through the heavenly Sanctuary to enter
where the father was and sit next to his
father or were they prophesying that
Christ was seated at the right hand of
the father or Christ sat at the right
hand of the father and stood up to walk
through the sanctuary when John the
Beloved apostle was given a vision of
the revelation of Jesus Christ and then
uh the person who sent in the question
presents three possible answers to the
question three hypothesis es hypothesis
number one always sit at the right hand
of the father without standing up to do
the levitical sanctuary cleansing MH so
in other words he's always sitting at
the right hand of God yeah hypothesis
number two the apostles were
prophetically explaining that Christ is
on the right hand with the statements
being in the present tense in hypothesis
number three Christ ascended and sat at
the right hand of the father but when
giving John his Revelation he stood to
walk through the
sanctuary and then uh we have
significance if
Christ Long sat on the right hand of the
father why is he walking through the
sanctuary in the Book of
Revelation moreover wasn't the walk
quick from the day he ascended and the
day after he arrived in heaven not
lasting hundreds of years until
1844 John the beloved was then only
narrating a vision mixing past and
future so the gist of the question
summarizing is why does the bible
portray Jesus sometimes as sitting and
sometimes as standing and the chronology
of when he sits and when he stands so
what can we uh say in answer to this um
inquir well the question it's is a very
interesting and I'm glad that this
person is actually studying and trying
to get some answers um one thing that I
you know do see from what he was
mentioning we mention in Acts chapter
verse um speaking of Jesus when he's
when Peter is speaking of the sermon of
who Jesus is and and where he's at it
mentions there that he was sitting to
the throne that he was you know before
this to the right right hand of God and
he sat next to him uh as a matter of
fact it says there in um verse I should
say uh verse
34 for David is not ascended into the
heavens but he said himself the Lord
said unto my Lord sit thou on my right
hand until I make thy foes thy foot
stool so he's mentioning that Jesus is
sitting at the right hand this is what
you know I think kind of throws him off
confuses a little bit because then of
course in in Acts chapter um 7 when we
see the stoning of
stepen then Stephen has a vision of
Jesus and he sees him standing and he
says there uh in verse 55 but he Steven
Fe full of the Holy Ghost looked up
steadfastly into heavens and saw the
glory of God and Jesus standing on the
right hand of God so he sees Jesus in
this particular moment
standing in the right hand of God now I
believe that we're trying to make uh
maybe his confusion is trying to figure
out why he's sitting in one part or or
said he's sitting and then why he's
standing over here and I think that this
is a question that maybe it's better to
answer as far as what the meaning of not
the location specifically of where he's
standing or not but really what is the
role of Christ and just to kind of add a
little bit more of a a thought is also
remember that in the moment that Steven
was stoned it was the Fulfillment of the
490 year prophecy that was given to the
Jewish Nation to remain as God's
peculiar and chosen people at at his
stoning it was the Fulfillment of that
time of Grace if you will to the Jewish
nation and so as heus Christ standing
there denotes some sort of fulfillment
of time of the moment that Christ
executes a I would say not of a judgment
necessarily but the time is finished for
the nation to be as a nation uh given
the opportunity to be the people of God
so I think that that's the only relevant
information of the experience of of
Steven but why is exactly you know is he
sitting is he standing I think that is
something that is not really understood
correctly for by our our reader and I
think pastor we probably have to explain
to him that is not just is not so Rel
that that experience is not so important
to know as far as what his role is
because I believe it's also and we will
see through this inspiration that Christ
is presented as one that stands and
walks among the candlesticks so this is
something that I want you know maybe you
can help me answer this but uh this is
where I think that the question he has
is coming from
okay uh let's read the verses uh on
Steph specifically being that his
question begins with Steven it's in Acts
chapter 7 beginning with verse 54 right
when they heard these things they were
cut to the heart he's giving this speech
to the Sanhedrin yeah pretty angry and
they nashed at him with their teeth but
he being full of the Holy Spirit gazed
into heaven and saw the glory of God and
Jesus standing at the right hand of God
mhm now there's two views about when
stepen is seeing
Christ the first view is that he's
seeing Jesus after his
Ascension and the other view is that
he's being transferred to the second
coming of Christ and he's seeing Jesus
at the right hand of God at the second
coming um you know I don't know whether
I can really define whether it's one or
the other but I can I can definitely say
that this idea of Christ CH uh standing
at the right hand of God uh or sitting
at the right hand of God and coming in
the Clouds Of Heaven is found also in
Matthew CH
26:64 where it clearly is speaking about
the second coming Jesus says to Kus that
the heavens will be open and you will
see the son of man sitting at the right
hand of God so um in some places he sits
and some places he stands and sometimes
he walks mhm you know know we should not
be focused on
geography because as you mentioned we're
dealing with functions yeah you know he
he um sits because he's the king of the
king Kingdom of
Grace Hebrews chapter 4 says that we're
need to approach the throne of grace
that we might find help so in that sense
uh Jesus is sitting because he's King of
the kingdom of Grace when Revelation
speaks about him walking among the
candlesticks that means that he's
supervising to make sure that the light
of the church doesn't go out in a moment
uh we can read that very significant
statement and when he's actually sitting
at the right hand of God it's because he
rules over the church he's the head of
the church uh so we're to understand uh
the locations of Jesus in terms of
function not in terms of geography uh
when Jesus comes the second time for
example uh let me just read there in
Matthew 26 and verse
64 Matthew 26 and verse 64 where Jesus
is speaking to
cifas uh he says
um it is as you have said nevertheless I
say to you Hereafter you will see the
son of man sitting at the right hand of
the power and coming in the Clouds Of
Heaven so here when he comes he's
sitting MH right yeah but on the other
hand in in Revelation chapter 19 he is
coming sitting on a horse yeah yeah
exactly so so you know what is being
described here is not so much uh whether
he's sitting or whether he's uh s where
he's on a horse sitting on a throne or
on a horse the point is that the second
coming of Jesus is portrayed differently
in uh Revelation chapter 6 it's talking
about him coming as king of kings and
Lord of lords he's sitting on the throne
in Revelation chapter 19 he's coming as
a mighty conqueror as a warrior right so
they're defining different functions of
Christ not that not that he's located in
a certain place from the time of his
Ascension and Pastor I think this is a
very important Point you're mentioning
because as as we see if he's standing
meaning he's interceding as well you
know his function of intercessor uh and
I think that's probably where if we were
to apply something would be more like
you said the function over the location
or or the the situation that is
happening and so because also Christ in
Revelation chapter one you know he sees
as you mentioned he sees them walking in
the candlesticks but then in chapter 10
he also sees Jesus standing you know
with one foot in one side and the other
foot you know in another side and so he
sees these elements of Jesus role in
what he's in the function he's doing
imagine if he was to sit for eternity I
mean for thousands of years just sitting
is really more about the role that he
takes when he's sitting is a role of of
King when he's perhaps standing he's
interceding or he's in the Judgment some
sort you know in the experience of
judgment or interceding so I think this
is mainly what the Lord wants describe
through these positions of Jesus being
standing or or sitting yeah the the
seven
candlesticks are symbolic of seven
stages of church history right and Jesus
is walking in the midst of church
history making sure that the light of
the church never goes out because you're
dealing with candlesticks the
candlesticks have oil and the oil gives
light and Jesus is to make sure that at
every stage of church history the light
of the church never goes out yeah that
the oil of the Holy Spirit the church
has it all the time right right uh so uh
once again the emphasis is on
function uh the emphasis is not on uh a
geographical location where he's at amen
amen okay I hope that that's helpful uh
by the way uh we could mention other
verses Revelation 3:21 where Jesus
overcame and he sat with his father on
his throne the father says sit at my
right hand he says to Jesus uh but in
first John 2:5 he stands before the
father as intercessor right and he walks
among the seven candlesticks so I hope
that uh the answer to this question uh
has been clear I hope so yes okay now uh
this question comes from
stepen from the United
Kingdom uh it actually is two questions
what were the types of sacrifices that
God instructed the children of Israel to
bring for different occasions uh the
second question is did jeffa actually
sacrifice his daughter to God by killing
her if so under which of the sacrifices
in the first question above would jeffa
sacrifice fall into
well he he obvious God did not expect
him to sacrifice his daughter but we'll
come back to that one let's talk about
sacrifices first okay the first um I
think it's important for for our friend
to know Stephen that in Leviticus which
which speaks of the different type of
sacrifices or offerings that were asked
of the people of God to
bring during their ceremonials during
their experience was one was called the
burnt off offering that was you know a a
gift uh of atonement of sin and for or
for prayer or praise so that burnt
offering was the type of sacrifice that
most traditionally we know of the one
that will bring for the sing offering
then we had the offering of grain which
was a kind of a gift of Thanksgiving to
the Lord of thankfulness for for his
goodness for his you know I guess his
Providence
then we had the offering of fellowship
or or peace this was an offering that
was between in the fellowship between
God and the people of God so as again as
a type of symbol of peace or fellowship
with the Lord then we had an offering of
purification or or sin that was
specifically for some sort
of things that you wanted to be cleansed
of specific sins that you wanted to be
cleansed of and that's something that
you would bring as a specific gift or
offering and then you had the offering
of reparation or guilt so if you made a
mistake or you had wrong something wrong
for someone you had to not only you know
repay the what you had stolen or
whatever you had done but also you had
to bring an offering to the Lord
for this reparation or guilt so those
are the five if you will the five types
of offerings that were in the Old
Testament in the levitical law um now I
guess this also will help him understand
what is judges 11 about because that's
the the second question you know but
these are the five elements and those
are found all in Leviticus it will be
too many verses to read but you have uh
you know all through Leviticus you have
these five elements of or types of
sacrifices or offerings that the Lord uh
accepted or wanted from his people okay
the the gist of the question is which of
those sacrifices does the sacrifice of
Jeff Jeff's daughter yeah
so so let's read let's read about Jeff's
sacrifice so
uh that's found in judges 11 right and
uh verse 34 through verse
36 it says
here and jeffa came to mispe unto his
house and behold his daughter came out
to meet him with trembles Tim Timber and
with dances and she was his only child
beside her he had neither son nor
daughter and he came to pass when he saw
her that he rent his clothes and said
alas my daughter thou Hast brought me
very low and thou are one of them that
trouble me for I have opened my mouth
unto the Lord and I cannot go back
because he had promised to
sacrifice the first first person that he
saw the first thing that came the first
thing that came yeah he didn't specify
that's kind of a mistake and then he
says and verse 36 and she said unto him
my father if thou H has opened thy mouth
unto the Lord do to me according to that
which had processed out of thy mouth for
as much as the Lord had take Vantage
Vengeance for thee of thine enemies even
of the children of Amon and she said
unto her father
L um let this thing be done for me let
me alone for two months that I may go up
and down up the mountains and bewail my
virginity
I and my fellows and he said and he said
go and he sent her away for two months
and she went with her Companions and
bewailed her virginity upon the
mountains and it came to pass at the end
of the two months that she returned unto
her her father who did with her
according to his vow which he had vowed
and she knew no man and it was custom in
Israel that the letters of Israel went
yearly to lament the daughter of jeffa
the gileadite for four days in a
year so that's sort of the this end of
the
story uh but I think Pastor a question
is like you know did he sacrifice his
daughter like like a burnt offering
that's a a very hard question a lot of
people have this question yeah you know
but I personally don't believe that even
though it doesn't you know because I
think I do think that the emphasis of
the story is in the emphasis of she
lamenting her virginity if you see she's
not lamenting that she's going to be
killed or sacrificed she's lamenting
that she will know she will not know any
man she will not be married ever so I
believe that Jeff was when he rashly
said I will sacrifice and I will burn an
offering to the Lord when he comes you
know when I come back he realized that
he could not necessarily kill a woman in
sacrifice because that was Abomination
before the Lord as a matter of fact you
would not mention he would not be
mentioned in the book of Hebrews as a
man of Faith had he got done such a
thing so I do believe that the main
element is that she said
look you need to I'll be a sacrifice a
Living Sacrifice if you will I will
never married I will be committed to the
Lord for my life but this is where I
think the emphasis is that she was
lamenting her virginity as she's going
to be without a child or a husband for
her life and that's kind of uh indicated
by the text itself so it's says go and
he sent her away for 2 months mhm and
she went with her friends and bewailed
her virginity on the mountains yeah and
it was so at the end of the two months
that she returned to her father and he
carried out his vow with her which he
had vowed she knew no man and it became
a custom in Israel there's nothing about
uh a sacrifice being offered on the
altar yeah however supposing that uh
jeffa did make a vow to s offer her in
sacrifice the Bible teaches that if you
make a vow that is contrary to God's
will yeah you can break your vow so if
jeffa did sacrifice his daughter to the
Lord he was disobeying the Lord because
God forbids child sacrifice right he
says you shall not burn your kids in the
fire and so it's inconceivable that God
would have accepted uh if he had indeed
sacrificed her I think that really what
we have here is something similar to
Hannah
dedicating uh Samuel to the Lord mhm she
was deprived of having her having him
right growing up with her but he
dedicated Samuel or she dedicated Samuel
to the Lord and Samuel was in the house
of the Lord the rest of his life uh and
so I see something similar here I don't
even think that jeffa was was uh going
to live up to his vow to put her on the
Altar and plunge a knife into her and
sacrifice her that's right and you know
Pastor because the sacrifices in
Leviticus uh when he speaks of
sacrifices it also included the idea of
grains offered to the Lord as a
sacrifice and they would even you know
they would use them as a way to to give
an offering there was this idea that it
would be allowed to to change if you
could not you know necessarily fulfilled
because of your lack of financial
circumstances to offer a lamb you could
offer something else and his offering
was not of sin he was not offering this
was not a a a a vow of of sin which
would make it different this was a vow
of thankfulness of a relationship with
the Lord so I do see that in looking at
the types of sacrifices in Leviticus you
do have these different types for
different options uh for different
things I think this will allow to the
priests to say Jeff you know um you know
um you can put your daughter in
sacrifice of the Lord meaning she serve
the Lord forever that's it you know but
not really killing her burn offering
like like some people think so so I
think that that is the best approach by
the way the Bible does teach that uh if
you make a vow that's contrary to God's
will yeah you can break your vow um you
know for example when um herodias uh
brought her daughter in salomi and and
the King said I'll give you whatever you
ask up to half the kingdom yeah uh Herod
should have broken his vow absolutely uh
because uh he had made a vow contrary to
the Lord's will amen so anyway well our
time is up it flies by when you're
having a good time studying scripture
thank you for joining us today God bless
you and keep you in his care and we hope
to see you next time in our next program
when we answer questions God bless you
see you next
time
[Music]